we introduce the idea of spinning in a
hallway visual visualization mental
model for learning attitude your boy
claims clean even your arm spinning if
you have a yoga mat or something like
that a code you can use that as a nice
visual guide you can put ain't down on
your floors you can actually stand in a
physical Holloway but playing with that
thinking with that really intuitively
make a lot more sense of what you're
doing with your boy so the idea is that
there's a wall the right all the left
look down the hallway your arms are boy
be on either walk or you face to face
then we did this great exercise that
gets us playing with moving our arms in
split time same direction so we're all
lined up in the hallway and we're all
going to start out there putting our
right hand forward and move in back
making making sure that we're touching
the imaginary walls and the smacking the
person runner behind us and so now we
lift our left hand up all the way up and
down down left or right back so these
four cardinal points around the circle
and this very happily starts training
you to keep your hands and your coy very
naturally did you keep it in your arms
on clean planes in the hallway moving
your toes Oh body crank your shoulders
but certainly that here Connie and it's
also hitting the sport cardinal
directions in the human body we also
play with split time arms facing one of
the hallway walls and safe same four
cardinal directions apply we start out
with fingers pointing together this son
our focus point to come back to hear
hear hear hear hear and eventually
getting the timing so that both hands
and ultimately both boy are circling in
the same direction in my arms your
wheels you're both rolling but they're
they're doing so in a timing that split
apart and in this case what that means
is they keep coming back to the central
focus point getting used to sensing how
your boy are always coming back to that
central focus point so we practice a few
things without a point first I like to
do that because unless your super Jedi
mind tricks over person your point we'll
just hover there and spit themselves
with your body so then we try to deploy
we got you gotta like be able to spit
them going the same direction like
wheels roll in the same direction on the
ball shift the timing so that they're
doing it in split time so that one's
dropping down
from there you can play around with
keeping the timing but like not even
moving around but notice how they always
want your timings on now is keep clean
up the central point and as another one
you can play with pushing one farther
away and bring on a little closer your
tummy this allows you to bring your your
boy your arms little closer together but
the same thing is still happening but
one boy is falling down a little low on
is coming up you can play with switch it
goes that's a nice projector progress
and to work with and of course you want
to do people their way to partner boy we
got it right boy we played with
basically spinning personally we were
spinning with ourselves same time same
direction super simple spin but with our
partner we were lining up
I mean in that same way so my partner
timing with tom is split time and you
know if you keep bugging your your
partner's right in that central focus
point but people to with you then your
timing too is going to work or spacing
so we're basically toe-to-toe each other
smacking to look forward try and keep
this time and just get to know how that
felt which brings up the point that when
you're spending with a partner you go to
communicate and sometimes you try to
chase each other around and fix each
other's timing and that number actually
doesn't make them for you so it's good
to choose rosal say hey I'm the
timekeeper hey hey hey okay so we did
that then we also experimented a little
bit with stepping up offset so now my I
move over so that only
my eat my feets is lined up with his so
that allows us to get a little closer
and get get our point in between each
other that was some fun timing and
spacing exercise and then we got the
good stuff the good stuff stalls so I
real quickly play with just kind of like
swinging a stall you're spending reverse
swinging it up let it fall down
eventually you can actually do it up
stall there and then you're spending
forward dropping them over in front of
you and it just so happened that lights
up all nice all right here we go then we
talked about doing those things with
focusing on the breath for a specific
move which really I found really helps
so like when I go over okay so we did a
bunch of that then we actually we play
with turning without quite first so that
we don't their bodies on you and so what
we did is very much Kito once again
we're standing a little bit offset so my
left foot and his left foot is on the
same line now we're going to snap past
each other sure we miss each other the
back look our finger essentially blind
up again
like that but it's different we're good
real surrounding Phillip so you actually
try in front of me ha that's pretty much
the meat of what we went through for
extra bonus actually
good